[Music]
the john o'labby has asked three
questions i'll i'll probably just take
one out of them okay others can have a
chance
how many times would man be sealed
before probation i think this is in
reference to if someone were to fall
away from the truth someone was in the
truth would they be sealed then and then
they fall away and then they come back
are they sealed again
someone sealed in the context of
revelation 7 and revelation 14 will not
fall away
you're following me someone on whom the
seal is placed
the the the the investigative judgment
is going on when a seal is pissed on a
person that person won't fall away
are you following me from christ
the person is sealed that's the purpose
of a seal you are sealed you set you
know it's a sign seal delivered as that
common the saying goes you're sealed you
won't fall away from christ
can you make a mistake yes that's not
falling away from jesus christ you will
not fall away from christ so when the
when the decrees goes forth he that is
unjust let him be unjust he that is holy
let him be holy still there is no
falling away from the holy person and
there is no coming to christ for the
unholy person when you're sealed you
seal that's it that's why you seal them
here in your forehead you've made up
your mind and nothing can change you
from that
amen reminds you the song i've got my
mind made
all right
all right so let me not sing today